bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro Cordero la
victoria de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
en las elecciones presidenciales de
Brasil de 2022 es un nuevo capítulo en
la vida de este carismático líder de la
izquierda latinoamericana una figura
fundamental en la historia política y
social reciente de su nación que vuelve
a la presidencia 12 años después con la
promesa de reconstruir su país es por
ello que en France 24 repasamos sus
orígenes y su trayectoria
Lula da Silva es El séptimo hijo de una
familia extremadamente humilde del
estado de pernambuco nacido en 1945
emigró junto a sus familiares al Estado
de Sao Paulo siendo un niño y desde una
temprana edad tuvo que abandonar la
escuela Lula trabajó Desde niño como
vendedor ambulante y limpiabotas hasta
que los 15 años aprendió el oficio de
tornero en la industria metalúrgica una
profesión que lo acercaría al
sindicalismo con 23 años se involucró en
el sindicato de metalúrgicos y comenzó
una lucha por los derechos laborales de
un sector tan precario como el
metalúrgico que incluso le llevó a
perder un dedo meñique mientras
trabajaba además su reivindicaciones
laborales fueron de la mano con el
rechazo a la dictadura militar que se
hizo con el poder en Brasil tras un
golpe de estado en 1964 algo que lo
convertiría en una figura reconocida a
nivel nacional entre la clase en esa
búsqueda de la Democracia Lula fue uno
de los encargados de fundar el partido
de los trabajadores en 1980 y se
convirtió en un líder gracias a su gran
carisma su lucha política lo llevó a ser
condenado por la dictadura Aunque tras
la vuelta de la democracia en 1986 pudo
ser elegido diputado durante estos años
Lula da Silva se convirtió en el
principal opositor al oficialismo
llegando a postularse en hasta tres
elecciones seguidas entre el año 1989 y
el 1998
sin embargo perdió esos comicios debido
a que su partido que era de corte
trasquista se presentaba con propuestas
consideradas como radicales por la clase
media brasileña algo que hizo que con el
tiempo Lula moderase su propuesta para
ganar fuerza política a partir de
finales de los años 90 el presidente de
la república está mintiendo a la
sociedad brasileña solo sabe atender a
los intereses de Los especuladores
Internacionales y la política de aumento
de las tasas de interés esto significa
más desempleo quiebra de las Industrias
y de la agricultura hará los ricos más
ricos y a los pobres más pobres
La promesa política de Lula siempre giró
en torno a la mejora de la calidad de
vida de los millones de pobres que hay
en Brasil una de las naciones más
desiguales del mundo su discurso cobraba
mucho sentido por su pasado humilde e
hizo que ganara las elecciones tras tres
intentos fallidos en el año 2002 Lula se
convirtió en el primer presidente de las
imágenes obreros en ser elegido en su
país
la verdad es que estamos muy cerca del
mayor acontecimiento histórico de este
país que es elegir a un hombre que salió
de la fábrica para ser nombrado
presidente de la República del país más
importante de latinoamérica
más importante de América Latina su
gobierno se centró en promocionar varios
programas de ayudas sociales para las
personas más pobres de todos ellos el
más reconocido fue bolsa familia un
auxilio básico que proporcionaba unos 30
dólares mensuales a casi el 25% de la
población su aplicación fue muy positiva
y se estima que estas medidas sacaron de
la pobreza a unos 30 millones de
personas
otro político solo se acuerdan de los
pobres cuando es época de elecciones
pero yo me acuerdo los 365 días del año
porque sé donde nací De donde vengo Y a
dónde voy
un éxito que fue acompañado de un
crecimiento económico muy importante
Gracias al auge de las exportaciones de
materias primas Lula obtuvo una gran
aprobación que hizo que fuera reelegido
en 2006 y que a nivel internacional
Brasil ganará gran reconocimiento y se
convirtiera en un referente en América
Latina y entre las economías en
desarrollo
el legado de Lula fue recogido desde
2010 por su sucesora Dilma roussef pero
fue a partir de su retirada de la
política cuando los problemas surgieron
su partido se vio involucrado en
numerosos escándalos de corrupción Vilma
sufrió un impeachment en el año 2016 y
el mismo Lula fue acusado de lavado de
dinero y corrupción pasiva en el marco
de una trama de corrupción llamada
lavayato que implicó a decenas de
empresas y políticos brasileños
estas sospechas hicieron que el juez
Sergio Moro lo llevará la cárcel por más
de 500 días y lo apartará de poder
ejercer como político Aunque en 2019
Lula abandonó la prisión después de que
se declarara improcedentes su reclusión
y que todas las denuncias que tenía en
su contra fueran suspendidas o
archivadas por un defecto de forma el
supremo tribunal de Brasil Consideró que
el juez Sergio Moro prevárico contralula
y le cortó su libertad por lo que todas
las investigaciones por corrupción se
eliminaron Aunque nunca se llegó a saber
si Lula era culpable o Inocente de ellas
me comprometo aquí a decir la verdad
porque no creo que en Brasil haya hoy un
brasileño que esté en busca de la verdad
más que yo
tras su Liberación Lula se postuló como
la opción favorita para plantarle cara
al presidente Yair bolsonarom algo que
finalmente ocurrió tras una campaña
marcada por la polarización y el
enfrentamiento político
consiguió imponerse al presidente
ultraderechista Yair bolsonaro y acceder
a un tercer mandato con un discurso en
el que se buscó confrontar las políticas
ultraconservadoras y volver a los años
dorados de su presidencia algo que no
será fácil ya que el Brasil en el que ha
ganado Lula en 2022 no es el mismo en el
que había ganado en el año 2002 ya que
el país está muy polarizado y el
bolsonarismo su principal rival político
ha demostrado que llegó para quedarse
con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]